it's just a test video but I'm gonna try
to be showing you guys sorry how to go
and tilt and a lot of people have been
asking me how I assume like kind of 3d
and tilt my actual videos in Camtasia
Studio six so I'm going to show you how
so just look at my screen here just go
ahead and open up Camtasia Studio six
okay and what we're going to do is
import some media I've already imported
a camrec file and I'm just going to drag
it in for this example video and save it
as my HD preset which I showed you how
to video showed you a video on how to
make that already so go and watch that
one and now we're just going to zoom in
a little bit so you can see here this is
an example of my tilting now it's really
really simple to do this but I'm gonna
have to do a video on anyway because
it's hard to explain with words so
basically you're gonna do is hit that
zooming pan button right here and you
get a preview of that I tilt effect
right now so go to zoom and pan and if
you actually scroll down here this it
will usually look like this and they
will just be a little advanced button
just click that advanced button or
scroll further down and there you have a
tilt on the XY axis so if I suppose oom
out here see the preview window here and
you see the what you're doing here so if
I were to continue to play this and I'm
gonna look for a keyframe and let's wait
for it to find a keyframe here's a good
frame I want to show everyone right here
what I'm showing you in the start main
search box so I'm gonna go up and go up
I hit zoom and pan then I'm gonna zoom
down here to show them and then what I'm
gonna do you can see it in the preview
window I'm going to go down and go ahead
and tilt that a little bit just so it it
brings your attention right on what I'm
actually searching then when you're done
finishing that edit hit finish it play
wait for him to let type it in and
everything now when you're done with the
init you just finish it up by zooming
back let's go to zoom and pan again
finish up
yeah so that's how I do that a 3d tilt
thing when I'm going out editing my
Camtasia Studio six videos I hope that
was helpful if you have any other
tutorial requests or ideas just go ahead
and so and I will get back to you as
soon as I can
they have to sub and then send me a
message and I'll get back to it so
thanks for watching